[Music]
it was what happens when probation
closes
when probation closes what follows will
be the seven last place
christ leaves the most holy place and
he's going to come for his people but
before that they'll be there'll be
there'll be a critical situation on the
face of the earth the several space will
be poured out as an expression of god's
anger against iniquity and sin and the
world that generally i say generally has
rejected his his uh overtures of grace
his mercy his son by rejecting the
gospel in a certain sense we crucify
christ all over and so there'll be
tremendous trials and turmoil on the
earth tremendous turmoil on the earth
and that's when god's people have been
such such a difficult position not
because so much of the physical
condition but because they'll be
wondering am i right with god are all my
sins forgiven that will cause more
suffering for them than whatever the
wicked would be doing in trying to take
their lives so when probation closes
the seven last place will be poured out
which will cause tremendous uh chaos all
around the world in different parts of
the world not all seven hit all parts of
the world at the same time but the whole
world be affected one area or not with
the seven plagues and gospel will also
suffer but not the way the wicked will
suffer
so that's what will be going on uh after
probation closes no more mercy for the
earth no more mercy that's when his
wrath is poured out without mixture into
the cup of his indignation it'll be the
very first time that god's wrath will be
poured out without a shred of mercy even
during the flood eloise tells us those
parts of the world where weakness was
not widespread the destruction was not
that great
you see there was mercy it was not that
great but this time
god's burst god's wrath will be poured
out for the first time without mercy and
why is that because people will accept
the beast and his mark and his image
instead of accepting christ and his seal
and that's the reason why
the wrath of god will be poured out
total rejection of christ because to
reject truth is through christ simple as
that i say it again to reject truth is
to reject christ you may keep church but
reject christ and the wrath of god will
be poured out because people will reject
christ and they reject him by rejecting
his word and his word is condensed in
his law because the law is the all the
whole duty of man
the wrath of god on those who've
accepted the beast which is a false
system
and the mark of the beast which is a
unbiblical day of worship
and that's the reason god pours out his
wrath upon this earth
so it's essential that those listening
ask themselves
am i obeying god or am i obeying a
man-made system
there are some religious systems that a
man made
the system that saves is a system that
is god made and that's based on thus
saith the lord
by the way is that system that says the
seventh day is the sabbath of the lord
that's the system of god
amen amen and for those that are tuning
in and probably don't even understand uh
the detail of what is october 22 1844 uh
definitely you can just go ahead and
read upon daniel
and you can read actually
going into daniel chapter let me get it
right here let's see nine yeah
8 14 and 9 24 to 27. you know there's a
14 and you can see the 2
30s on there which is 230 years and also
highlighting upon the seven plagues
which is referenced in revelation
chapter 16. that's right also we're
looking at exactly the responsibility
the duty of man
which is the final verses of
ecclesiastes
thank you for those words and of course
remember probation starts at the house
of god
jesus christ
you